are you doing dr. Wallach I'm sure thank
you how can we help you I have a
question how does one get rid of eye
product issue who say like in Peyronie's
disease okay how old even what do you
weigh I'm 55 a hundred and seventy
pounds okay any other issues how about
pressure diabetes nope any history of
asthma bronchitis nope
any history of skin problems eczema
dermatitis psoriasis no okay
so no other issues no all right see here
Peyronie's of course is where the penis
instead of coming out straight
perpendicular to the body it kind of
especially with an erection goes off to
one side one direction or another
and obviously can be a positional
problem during sexual intercourse so
basically it requires a little bit of
support from two or three different
directions and shar what would you give
a guy that needs some hormonal support
weighs 170 pounds well I I would suggest
that he'd take these they're a test and
get on a lot of eggs and butter
okay and what basic program would you
give him on top of that I'd give him a
healthy brain and hard pack Tori yeah
very good excellent you got an A+ yeah
okay so that's where we need to start
Bob you need to get rid of all the bad
food the fried foods processed meat so
Allison glutens you want to take about
six eggs twice a day I get that
cholesterol level ups make more
testosterone you also need to hel
different heart packs per month to full
dose everything twice a day you need the
let's see here um these air tests as
char said which is a promoter of normal
male function as a tablet and so I'd go
ahead and take two or three of those
tablets twice a day two bottles a month
also I'd throw in the male support from
good herbs it's a tincture take two
doses a two bottles a month and let's
see here I think just for connective
tissue reasons I would also what was you
throw in for connective tissue stuff
Shar uh you could do the em Italian
where the using resources or tendons and
ligaments
yeah gluco gel MSM oh look MSM MSM yeah
I join the MSM take two pounds a month
of MSM bum I take through those tablets
twice a day and then call us every
couple of weeks and we'll walk you
through this